hey guys it's justine and today we're
actually shooting a podcast right now
and
i decided that in the middle of the
podcast i was going to do an unboxing so
that we could
just do the podcast and i could also
unbox my note 20 ultra 5g
i'm excited for you too check this thing
out i'm also here hi everyone
jenna's here and jenna what do you what
do you have oh well i already unboxed
mine but she already did um i want you
to be okay i want you i don't want to
see it experience it for yourself
okay this is really exciting so if you
guys are watching again on youtube this
is a part of our podcast
so you can go check that out put links
in the description anchor fm
same brain and if you're wondering why
it's called same brain this is my sister
jenna hello
we tend to have a lot of the same
thoughts but sometimes we have different
ones too but
for the most part same same brain for
the most part for the most part actually
think about this the other day because
you're left-handed which means you
probably utilize more of your right
brain and i'm right-handed which means i
probably utilize more of my left brain i
have learned a lot about myself trying
to
learn to solve a rubik's cube which i
can it's weird
because some of the teaching styles of
people that i've seen on youtube i
absolutely cannot comprehend what
they're saying when they're telling me
left and right
clockwise and counterclockwise that does
not compute in my brain
whatsoever when they tell me to go left
i will instinctively
not i just it takes me so long to think
about which way left is
that's not that's really not normal
right well is it right or is it left
what is the question because you said
right right okay oh
okay anyway so yeah that's what i was
thinking that also before i couldn't
you know fall asleep i was like wait a
minute same brain we both probably use
different
i see what you're saying creativity so
the brain side that you're not using
on me yeah oh wow
fun it's fun i i just got that oh
because i was still processing that's
that's totally fine there's a there's a
loose wire for no there's a little bit
of fluid
you hit your head i did hit my head
anyway ready should we do like a
no oh no how about this
oh
don't even know if it's in focus because
tyler's not here so it'll focus
eventually
we're relying on auto focus we love auto
focus all you have to say is
focus on it i'm lifting up the top of
the box now for our audio listeners
and here it is i'm looking at a very
very very shiny screen well you're going
to have to do it by the mic if you want
to have the full audio effect oh no no
i'm so i'm just i'm taking it out now i
just want to make sure that they
know exactly what i'm doing if they're
listening um
jenna's opening up a bottle of water
she's taking a drink here it is
okay i'm gonna flip it over oh wow oh
is that a sim card oh god they they've
conveniently what is that no that's
just a serial number okay let me take
let me take off the sticker now i'm
gonna give you guys
some some real real nice close-up sounds
of
i'm peeling off the back sticker now
ready here we go
oh did you hear it yeah i mean yeah
it's not it sounded okay is there
something on the front there is one on
the front okay get ready
oh i mean i've hyped there's also
stickies on the top it's not really as
important
what i love is that it's kind of the
back of it has more of like a matte sort
of texture so
it feels like it's not going to slip out
of your hand like a slippery seal
yeah and i'm always real smudgy i said
in mind that i'm super smudgy but i love
also that like the
camera notch has like a kind of shiny
shinier look to it yeah so very pretty
it's
interesting because the camera bump even
in videos like i didn't realize
how big that is it's big boy but the
camera bump
is essentially about the same size as
the s20
but the body of the note is actually
slimmer
so that's kind of interesting and
obviously it wouldn't be a note if it
didn't have
the s pen oh wow i took out the s pen
so the little pen has its nice little
home they also switched the side because
i think on the note
10 i think it was on this side actually
so that's kind of interesting
i love the color so the galaxy note 20
comes in three colors mystic bronze
mystic green mystic gray
i like that green that green looks
really nice too cool yeah the only thing
with the galaxy note 20 is
it's more of a plastic phone i've been
watching a bunch of people's videos i'm
sure you guys have
seen a ton of them as well but i don't
know which color i like the best i mean
i think the gold
so with this you can now do shortcuts
where you hold in this button and you do
like a little like
the latency has also been i guess
decreased because
before on previous note devices whenever
you would write you would be able to see
the the pen trail well now they've been
able to eliminate a lot of that so it's
almost like real time so i know i'm
jumping the gun here but if you do these
little moat like these little motions
it'll like go back or cool go home so
it's really cool so you just click the
button
on the s pen you do these motions and
they're like the little air shortcuts
that's pretty cool let's see what else
we have in this box
not much okay well we got it
fast charger oh no no no no no
no this is a super fast charger matthew
matthew he's upset i love
he's growling oh listen to his little
voice
he's missing his voice
so it has a usb charger as always
anything else in here no okay meant to
be afraid to tell you that
what there's nothing else in there
note 20 ultra has the 6.9 inch
display whereas the note 20 has the 6.7
inch display man i'm hyped to try this
out
hey turn on let's see i'm already on and
i'm already drawing
so i guess now we just go to yours
because yours is already set up
man looks amazing i haven't got to take
any photos yet on the note 20 ultra it
does have a 12 megapixel ultra wide
camera 108 megapixel wide angle 12
megapixel telephoto
and a laser af sensor now the note
20 not ultra it doesn't have the laser
sensor it just feels it feels very
top-heavy
yeah a little bit i mean it's got a big
boy camera notch
does but man i'm so excited to test this
out this is cool are you
what you're doing thanks so what i was
doing the other day was it's
like this uh you can draw you can use
the ar
on your on your front-facing camera and
you can hit record okay so i'm gonna hit
record and i can do a little drawing
also if you don't put the s pen back in
it will give you a very aggressive alert
really yeah i'm like what do you want
and i look down like oh
like put me back i'm like okay sorry
just try to connect to your wi-fi
network so it has her wi-fi network and
then under it it says very fast
thank you that is the best compliment i
think i've ever received do you remember
your password well yeah i'm not crazy
well i mean some people have like super
long whatever
you know what i'm excited that you're
here because i can send you your video
file with your uh
with their file sharing transfer system
well i wanted to try this yesterday when
i was
doing my unboxing but i was like oh
there's somebody here i'm here okay so
nearby share right now it's popping up
it says that share instantly with people
nearby
oh wow the screen looks amazing it's 120
hertz refresh rate it's 25
brighter what's the the battery on this
one i already said it 45
oh 100 milliamp hour really okay oh my
gosh look look
look look look it's happening it's
happening to share
devices turn by you have to drive to
turn on bluetooth location and wi-fi
yeah turn it on come on
it's on it's on it's on oops i closed it
you closed
i accept accept accept okay it's sending
and sending it's sent oh my god there it
is so she'll show them that you sent it
i can't have the same thing
same thing oh my gosh this is incredible
that was actually very quick that's cool
wow i also like that they did away with
the what was it like the hundred
x zoom oh that's 100 times zoom yeah
a little aggressive i think now it's 50
which is a little bit more reasonable i
just feel like the 100 it
was just it looked really not it was a
lot i mean
the fact that you could do that on a
smartphone i think was really cool
it was kind of showing like the
possibilities like this is something
that you could potentially do in the
future
and make this look really cool props to
samsung for like they're going all out
i mean i definitely tried to use it but
it's like if you're trying to do it
handheld and you're not stable it's
going to be a blurry mess
yeah i was not stable dude this screen
looks amazing
wait until you do a little drawing that
it needs to connect to a charger oh
geez i'm oh gosh i'm here use me as a
charger
i can charge myself off of you oh wait
just to turn it on yeah this is cool
okay i love that as wireless charging
i'm definitely looking forward to doing
a full review on this
so that'll be coming out so let's see in
a few weeks i think as soon as i can
get some time to spend with this oh
wireless power share you just hit that
okay so now i am going to charge me on
you
okay just don't put your camera on my
camera because i might scratch okay you
put your camera directly on my camera no
i didn't
your camera they're separate my camera's
not touching your camera
see oh okay i got it i got worried so
now you're charging your phone
on my phone so some other stuff that
they announced called the the unpacked
event
so they unpacked a lot i mean they
freaking unpacked so much stuff so they
came out with an update to the samsung
watch you guys know i'm a huge fan of
smart watches
so they have now integrated blood
pressure oxygen levels
uh ecg and of course just regular heart
rate and they also have samsung fitness
oh did you see that no i didn't the
event was very long it was kind of long
very very i had to do some other stuff
but i watched some of them and every
single youtuber had posted their videos
already so i was like
go watch samsung fitness was actually
really really cool so they did this demo
where the girl
uh had her samsung watch on it
integrated with the
the fitness app that they have like
samsung has all these workout activities
like i had no idea this like i didn't
yeah i didn't need that no
and then she was watching that on the
television and doing the
doing the workouts on her watch and then
you're able to like pause the workout on
your watch
but it all like syncs up to like the
samsung health which was really cool you
have been talking about the blood oxygen
for quite some time now like something
that you've wanted in a device
like for years a long time here's the
problem is a lot of that stuff takes a
lot to get through like the fda
and like health clearances because you
don't want to be like freaking people
out
wearing these devices and then you start
getting a high
blood pressure when it's not entirely
accurate especially with like those um
like wrist wearing blood pressure oh my
gosh yeah those are not accurate they're
not so i think that's really hard for a
device to be able to be
that one said device that is going to be
able to do it all for sure
for sure let me see i'm just going to
look it up here it's like it's you're
going to have to do it right if you're
going to do it
also you're still recording on that oh
if you're interested in that that's cool
but i'll stop that i will say that with
my apple watch like
there was a time i fell down like on
purpose and it's like did you fall
i did another time i fell down running
up the steps i tripped
i actually hit my arm really really hard
she looks like you
taking a tumble i was like i did but i'm
okay the fall accuracy of the apple
watch is pretty impressive there was
something that i was reading today
talking about the update
to the apple watch and the fall
detection because obviously they're
talking about you know
if samsung came out with this like
what's apple gonna do using
um the apple health like if you were to
fall and you don't respond
it would be able to call your emergency
contact emergency contacts will also
call
for like 911 or whatever and then it'll
read off
what has happened so it'll say so and so
may has fallen they have they're not
responsive this is their current heart
rate this was their heart rate before
the fall
this is the medication this is apples
apples okay it'll be able to tell them
like what medication you're on and it'll
be able to pull from your health data
that is already integrated into your
phone and obviously this is something
that you would have to give access to
and allow to happen but if this is like
a life or death situation like i don't
care if my watch is telling the
authorities my heart rate my weight my
height like all of this information like
that needs to be known no
for sure especially blood uh blood types
like that very important
still don't know mine so now at the end
of the podcast jenna let's see
what the charging is at so this is
wireless charging it says three hours 22
minutes until full i basically would be
sucking
the life out of your phone to give me
life i like it so cool the wireless
charging work i'm definitely looking
forward to checking this out i
absolutely love the color okay thank you
for watching if you guys want to check
out the full podcast where we talked
about a lot of
a lot of stuff but also a lot of nothing
a lot i will put a link in the
description anchor dot
fm slash same brain if you guys want to
check out jenna she also did an unboxing
slash jenna ezerik and there goes the
dumpster
you have to open the door because maddie
wouldn't go outside just sunbathed so
good
this is a silky little machine i'm
excited for you to test it out me too
set it all up i'm gonna go draw some
pictures the s-pen feels real good it's
nice and responsive and
super smooth so i'm excited i'm hyped
alright i'll see you guys later thanks
for watching